figurez vous que vous avez tous en vous
un organe qui est plastique
cet organe il pèse seulement 1 kg 5 soit
pas grand chose par rapport à notre
masse totale
et pourtant il est très gourmand puis
s'ils consomment environ 20% de
l'énergie que nous produisons chaque
jour et c'était même 50% de cette
énergie
quand on était enfant en plus d'être
gourmand cet organe il est très complexe
tellement complexe que personne ne le
comprend vraiment aujourd'hui
alors on s'est quand même deux trois
trucs on sait par exemple qu'il est
composé d'environ 200 milliards de
cellules qui sont très minutieusement
organisé entre elles alors comment
exactement s'est justement ce qu'on
comprend pas quoi qu'il en soit la
conséquence de cette organisation c'est
que cet organe il a pour ainsi dire des
super pouvoirs celui de nous faire rire
nous faire aimer nous faire apprendre
nous faire créer ou plus modestement à
priori en tout cas dormir manger et
bouger
évidemment vous l'avez compris cet
organe c'est bien notre cerveau qu'on
peut définir comme étant gourmand
complexe mais aussi plastique pourquoi
mais parce qu'avec ses 200 milliards de
cellules dont 100 milliards seulement
seraient des neurones le cerveau à la
tâche de faire en sorte que nous à
chaque l'instant soyons au mieux adaptée
à la situation que nous sommes en train
de vivre
et pour cela on a notre cerveau depuis
le jour de notre naissance voire même un
petit peu avant et pourtant si on se
replonge à ce moment là force est de
constater qu'on n'était peut-être pas au
mieux de notre forme et qu'on n'était
pas capable de faire ni d'exprimer grand
chose de très intéressant
alors on pourrait penser que notre
cerveau était alors pas du tout
performant
en réalité elle était surtout
extrêmement immature particulièrement
immature d'ailleurs si on le compare
avec celui de nos cousins les primates
alors on le compare souvent à ce moment
là à une éponge qui absorbe tout ce qui
passe mais plus précisément ça
ressemblerait à une boule de pâte à
modeler très malléable et donc très
plastique alors nous dès les premiers
moments de notre vie nous avons
effectivement utilisé cette immaturité
qui est synonyme de plasticité et ça
c'était une chance parce que dès les
premières expériences de notre vie dès
les premières nouveautés nos cerveaux a
généré des milliers de
nouvelles connexions les synapses entre
les milliards de neurones qui le
constituent et ce qui va offrir un
nombre de possibilités des changes entre
ces neurones qui va littéralement frôlé
l'infini est la conséquence est que nous
nous sommes capables d'apprendre tout un
tas de choses donc dans les premiers
mois au niveau moteur par exemple on a
été capable d'attraper un objet
intentionnellement comme cette petite
fleur et puis là tu aimes fallu attendre
deux trois mois de plus pour que nous
soyons capables de lâcher cet objet tout
aussi intentionnellement et puis on a
appris à marcher certains leur âge au
foot et au niveau cognitif aussi on
s'est développé à trois mois on s'est
mis à gazouiller pour communiquer puis
on a appris à parler on a appris à lire
on a appris à compter et puis bien
évidemment tellement plus donc
clairement dans les premiers moments de
notre vie notre cerveau est complètement
ouvert à plein de nouvelles expériences
et la conséquence est que nous nous
apprenons tout un tas de choses
alors maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
une fois adulte alors certaines
personnes peut-être certains d'entre
vous pensent qu'une fois la trentaine
passée dans notre cerveau il devient un
petit peu plus paresseux qu'il un peu
plus rigide mais finalement c'est
peut-être pas si bien connaître
alors c'est vrai que certains
apprentissages seront plus laborieux une
fois qu'on est adulte par exemple notre
cerveau est plus disposé à nous faire
apprendre le sanscrit à 4 ans à 40 ans
c'est indéniable en revanche on est
aussi plus capable de résoudre une
équation différentielle à 20 ans qu'à
deux ans si jamais on est capable de
résoudre à jamais une équation
différentielle c'est encore autre chose
en réalité c'est une idée qui est fausse
avec l'âge notre cerveau ne fait pas que
perdre ses aptitudes perdre ses neurones
et perd ses synapses
c'est une idée qui est faussée qui a eu
pendant très longtemps la tête assez
durs et c'était même un dogme en
neurosciences et un dogme et non c'est
pas par n'importe qui mais par cet homme
qui est un chercheur espagnol santiago
ramon y cajal c'est probablement une des
personnes qui a le plus contribué à la
contribution du cerveau il a pendant des
années minutieusement étudié la
structure du système nerveux il en a
fait de magnifiques d'inscription qui
font toujours écoles aujourd'hui et dans
parmi ces contributions il à déterminer
l'existence d'une neurones comme celui
qui l'a dessinée ici comme étant l'
unité structurelle et fonctionnelle du
système nerveux ce qui lui a valu
probablement à raison le prix nobel de
physiologie et médecine en 1906 qu'il a
partagé avec italien camillo cole j
ramon y cajal écrit en 1928 dans les
centres adultes les voies nerveuses sont
des choses fixe fini est immuable tout
peut mourir mais rien ne peut se
régénérer
pourtant à la même époque une femme
alice hamilton qui deviendra d'ailleurs
la première femme professeur à harvard
observe la présence de ce qui semble
être de nouvelles cellules dans le
cerveau de rats adultes mais il n'y
avait pas la preuve que ces cellules
étaient des neurones donc cette
observation est tombé dans l'oubli
il a fallu attendre des décennies les
années 60 pour que jo zette apps man
remettent le couvert est lui aussi
observe ce qui semble vraiment être des
nouveaux neurones dans le cerveau de
rats adultes et il pense
qu'effectivement le cerveau conserve
cette capacité à générer des neurones de
cette neuro génèse mais que se serait
limitée à seulement deux régions
cérébrales dont l'hippocampe
l'hippocampe c'est cette structure qui
est ici niché dans no love temporaux et
qui est nécessaire à ce que nous
apprenions et à ce que nous mêmes
horizons c'est à dire que sans
hippocampe on est incapable de former de
nouveaux souvenirs
donc le fait qu'il pourrait y avoir la
naissance continue de neurones dans la
région qui contrôle la formation des
souvenirs c'est quand même un petit peu
intrigant mais les travaux datent man
ont été largement ignorés et puis un
petit peu considéré aussi comme
hérétique puisque ça allait à l'encontre
du dogme de santiago ramon y cajal mais
d'autres observations ont continué à
faiblir ce dogme notamment celles
réalisées par elisabeth gould qui finira
par déterminer en 1998 qu'il ya bien la
présence de nouveaux neurones à coup sûr
dans l'hippocampe de primates adultes et
c'est cette même année que le double-top
pour de bon des chercheurs ont eu l'idée
d'étudier le cerveau de cinq patients
qui sont morts des suites d'un cancer et
qui avait reçu préalablement l'injection
d'une molécule qui permet de suivre la
prolifération des cellules et donc
depuis suivre l'amplification des
tumeurs et bien ces chercheurs ont
retrouvé cette molécule dans des
neurones de l'hippocampe de ses patients
c'est à dire qu'effectivement l'homme
adulte est toujours capable de générer
des drones dans son hippocampe
ça veut dire que moi et vous nous sommes
toujours en train de produire une route
non nous
hippocampe la personne la plus âgée de
cette étude avait 72 ans est lui aussi
on a pu retrouver les nouveaux neurones
dans son hippocampe ça veut dire que
cette neurogénèse se fait même à un âge
avancé qu'est ce que ça représente
combien de neurones laisse finalement
dans notre hippocampes et redon pour
répondre à cette question il ya des
chercheurs qui ont une idée assez
géniale
il se trouve qu entre 1955 et 1963 aux
etats unis c'est la guerre froide avec
tous les essais nucléaires qui vont avec
qui vont provoquer une très forte
augmentation de la concentration de
carbone 14 dans l'atmosphère et les
chercheurs ont eu l'idée d'aller mesurer
le carbone 14 présents dans l'adn des
neurones qui sont nés pendant cette
période afin de les dater comme on le
ferait avec un fossile montré très
précis et donc grâce à ça ils ont pu
estimer la naissance quotidienne des
neurones dans notre hippocampe 2400 par
jour
1400 nouveaux neurones dans notre
hippocampe par jour ça veut dire à peu
près 60 par heure alors que ce soit
clair le dogme est bien tombé ramon y
cajal là dessus en tout cas avaient tort
puisque le produisons des nouveaux
neurones
chaque jour parmi 400 c'est super mais
c'est pas grand chose par rapport à 100
milliards
donc est ce qu'on peut faire quelque
chose pour améliorer cette neurogénèse
mais c'est simple les paramètres les
principaux paramètres qui permettent
d'améliorer et d'optimiser la
neurogénèse ils sont hyper simple à
implémenter dans notre vie puisqu'il
s'agit 1 de l'activité physique et 2 de
l'activité cognitive
mais ces paramètres sont interdépendants
et donc il faut nécessairement ils sont
complémentaires et il faut
nécessairement avoir les deux a exercé
les deux pour optimiser notre
neurogénèse si je place une roue dans la
cage de rongeurs vous l'avez tous
observés ils vont se précipiter dedans
et vont se mettre à courir acer lassabe
le mans et bien on observera dans
l'hippocampe de ces animaux plus de
nouvelles cellules qui se forme dans
leur hippocampe que dans l'hippocampe
des animaux qui n'avaient pas de roue
mais seulement 10% de ces cellules vont
survivre à long terme
ils auront la chance de devenir des
vrais neurones mature et fonctionnel
donc on dit que l'activité physique
permet la prolifération de nouvelles
cellules mais ne permet pas leur survie
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
garder ces cellules et en faire des
neurones c'est extrêmement simple il
faut s'en servir
il faut apprendre il faut voir nouvelle
expérience il faut côtoyer des
congénères en autres termes il faut
enrichir notre environnement et c'est
donald m qui a fait dans les années 40
le premier constat de ces effets
bénéfiques de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'environnement enrichi tout
simplement parce qu'ils ramenaient des
rats du laboratoire chez lui pour qu'il
s'amuse avec ses enfants et s'est aperçu
que ses râles à ceux qui avaient joué
avec les enfants et bien il était
beaucoup plus performant ensuite dans
les tests de laboratoire comme trouver
la sortie d'un labyrinthe et on sait
aujourd'hui que les animaux qui sont
placés dans un environnement enrichi qui
consiste tout simplement à placer un
grand groupe d'animaux dans des grandes
cages avec tonnes d'objets qu'on va
changer régulièrement
eh bien ces animaux là en réalité ils
n'ont pas plus de nouvelles cellules qui
se forme dans leur hippocampe
mais la proportion de ces cellules qui
va survivre à long terme devenir des
vrais neurones mature qui fonctionne
elle va être largement augmenté donc si
je résume
il vous faut à avoir une activité
physique pour générer plein de nouvelles
cellules dans votre hippocampes et puis
deux avoir une activité intellectuelle
et sociale de manière à ce que ces
petites cellules et la chance de devenir
des baux neurones nature et
fonctionnaires qui permettront à votre
hypocrisie autant mieux fonctionner il
est nécessaire pour les capacités
d'apprentissage et de mémoire et
particulièrement ce qu'on appelle la
mémoire spatiale et la mémoire pour
textuel donc en gros c'est grâce à votre
hypothèque ou aussi un petit peu
certainement avec votre téléphone que
vous allez retrouver où vous avez garer
votre voiture en sortant d'ici alors moi
personnellement je prendrai le métro
mais je vais tout à fait utiliser le
niveau comme pour trouver là la station
la plus proche donc ça c'est la mémoire
spatiale la mémoire contextuel c'est
tout simplement mémoriser tout ce qui
constitue le contexte d'un événement de
notre vie alors les odeurs les couleurs
la température les sensations qu'on
avait à ce moment-là tout ça ça fait
partie du contexte et l'hippocampe cote
pour ça et donc à chaque instant dans
notre hippocampe
on a des nouvelles cellules qui se forme
et il se trouve que ces cellules ses
neurones qui sont d'abord immature sont
justement particulièrement plastique
c'est à dire qu'ils vont
particulièrement répondre à ça une
stimulation plus que les autres donc en
gros là maintenant je suis en train de
solliciter plus particulièrement dans
votre hippocampes des neurones qui sont
nés il ya deux trois semaines et qui
sont d'autant plus nombreux si vous avez
une activité physique
et là où c'est génial hic c'est dingue
même si c'est pas complètement prouver
c'est que ces mêmes neurones ce sont ces
mêmes neurones qui se réactive rond le
jour où vous remémorer cette
présentation ici dont clairement les
manipulations qui permettent d'améliorer
notre nouveau génèse devrait être en
mesure de permettre l'amélioration de
nos capacités d'apprentissage et de
mémoire et il ya une condition pour
lesquelles ces capacités sont fortement
endommagés vous connaissez tous c'est la
maladie d'alzheimer donc la maille
d'alzheimer est une maladie
neurodégénérative est le cerveau subi
des dommages qui sont dramatiques
avec la perte de milliers de neurones
particulièrement dans l'hippocampe
d'où les problèmes de mémoire et on
estime en france aujourd'hui à 900 mille
le nombre de cas de la maladie
d'azheimer 35 millions dans le monde et
l' oms estime que si rien n'est fait en
2030 65 millions de personnes seront
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer
mais est-ce que de même dans ces
conditions extrêmement difficiles où le
cerveau ont subi des dommages qui sont
très lourds est-ce qu'ils aient tout
fait toujours preuve de capacité
d'adaptation est ce qu'il fait toujours
preuve de plasticité et est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas utiliser ces ressources là
cette plasticité pour lutter contre ce
type de pathologie et donc pour
commencer à répondre à ça ici à toulouse
on a placé des souris dans un
environnement enrichi comme je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure mais ces souris
sont un peu particulière puisque elle
exprime un gène modifié qui va faire que
d'une manière inévitable
elles vont développer la maladie
d'alzheimer avec l'âge et la question
qu'on s'est posée c'est est ce qu'il
existe une période dans la vie de ces
animaux
c'est à dire un moment dans le décours
de la pathologie ou le fait d'être
soumis à de très fortes stimulation
sensorielle et sociale pourrait
compenser les dommages liés à la
pathologie et donc on a tout simplement
placer ces animaux dans un environnement
enrichis pendant dix semaines de leur
vie seulement avant et après ces 10
semaines
elles étaient dans leur cage un peu plus
triste de laboratoire mais toutes les
souris n'avait pas le même âge au moment
les a mises dans l'environnement
stimulant certains avaient trois mois
donc c'est très jeunes l'ont encore
aucun signe de la maladie
d'autres avaient cinq mois c'est l'âge
on commence à voir les premiers troubles
liés à la pathologie et puis en dernier
avait dix mois donc là sont assez âgés
et elle montre à la fois des troubles de
comportement et des troubles neuro
pathologie qui ressemble à ce qu'on voit
chez les patients alzheimer avérés et à
notre grande surprise nous avons observé
que les animaux qui avait été placé
pendant dix semaines seulement dans
l'environnement enrichi à l'âge de trois
mois et 5 mois
eh bien ces animaux là une fois âgées se
comporter exactement comme des souris
qui n'avaient pas la pathologie donc le
simple fait pendant une petite période
de leur vie d'avoir très fortement
stimuler leurs capacités cognitives et
leurs capacités sociales a finalement
suffi à supprimer l'expression
comportementale de la pathologie alors
est-ce que l'effet bénéfique de
l'environnement enrichi ici est passé
par une amélioration de la neurogénèse
ou est-ce que c'est lié à la stimulation
d'un autre type de plasticité de notre
cerveau ça c'est ce qu'on cherche
aujourd'hui à déterminer mais quoi qu'il
en soit on n'est absolument pas au bout
de nos surprises quant aux capacités de
notre cerveau ses capacités de
plasticité et vous l'avez compris ce
qu'il est important de faire c'est la
curieuse que indéniablement où vous êtes
puisque vous êtes ici aujourd'hui il
faut se servir de notre cerveau et on
pourra probablement à terme comprendre
encore mieux comment ils fonctionnent et
trouver les moyens de solliciter cette
plasticité pour que notre cerveau soit
plus fort plus performants tout notre
vie et surtout plus résistants face aux
pathologies et en attendant qu'on
comprenne tout ça le message il est
simple utilisez votre cerveau soyez
curieux allez courir aller danser allez
voir vos amis parce que votre cerveau à
tout cela il est toujours plastique
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
alors profitez-en
[Applaudissements]